[Music]
all right let's go to Ashley what's up
Ashley hello what's
up hi Dr johnone thank you for having me
on your show you got it Ashley what's up
um so my question is how do you mourn
the loss of your marriage while staying
in
it
um
so basically we're together and we're
raising a family but we're not
together why we not seeing other people
but we're
not do you want to
be of
course does the person you're married to
want to
be um if he does he doesn't show like
talk into the phone for me talk into the
phone his words and his actions don't
say that um
I begged for counseling I beged for I
mean we can do anything I a book a
podcast a whatever he wants to come up
with um to try to like
rekindle but I mean ultimately
like everything I'm trying is being met
with
nothing nothing that's on his end and
I'm to the point that it's like I just
need to get over him but I'm going to be
with him for a long time so it's hard to
get over somebody you see every day why
have you done that to
yourself why are you choosing this this
path
forward cuz I have no ideas like what
else to do going um I wanted to see a
therapist but it's not financially in
the books nor do I have child care for
that
um I stay home with the babies and my
husband work yeah I I I don't I'm GNA
say this it's going to sound harsh but I
don't believe
that I believe you stay at
home I believe that you've could figure
out a way to get to a counselor in fact
I'm going to take that excuse from you
I'm going to give you three months of
free better help counseling every week
that you can do at your
home how do you do it with kids cuz I'm
like I'm the primary parent so how old
are your kids one and three do they not
take
naps um they're napping right now but
they haven't figured out how to get them
to nap where I get more than like 30
minutes okay like I guess aone time do
you have a friend with a 10-year-old who
could come over and play oh
why don't you a pretty antisocial person
which I am social I take my kids to do
things but I haven't really met people I
guess and my only um like I guess friend
that I talk to has a newborn and a
one-year-old or a twoy old now
okay my parents help out when they can
but you've created a world that you
can't win
in and you've created a world that
um where you are this
sole victim inside of this trapped house
and I don't buy
it I think you could do different things
why why are you why are you thinking so
little of
yourself I don't know I guess it's just
a a habit I've gotten
into but please don't you're worth more
than
this everything you're involved with is
worth more than
this your original question you don't
mourn a marriage and just like you're CH
you're CH you're mourning is something
that happens when something
dies are you telling me that right now
this early in your marriage you're
choosing
death I mean it's not super early we're
13 years in
but um I'm not I feel like I have to
choose it I feel like if I I mean I've
beged I've twed and if he's not
interested like what am I what am I
supposed to do love myself only and
pretend like it's him that loves
me no behavior is a language he has left
you he's just too much of a coward to
say it out
loud
well sometimes you need to hear it he
has stopped being married to
you or I'll even say it this way he is
cheating on you with
silence yeah like a th% like we're fine
with all the big stuff I guess in life
like working through finances and I
guess the normal stuff people
fight about those aren't the big things
the big things are do you love
me the big things are I'm watching my
wife drown and I don't know how to
help yeah and I've used those words like
especially at night when I'm at my wt's
end and I'm also pregnant and do with
our third at the beginning of the year
and I'm
like sometimes I just need a minute and
I'll tell him that and he doesn't get it
or he doesn't care is the way I perceive
it
and like how am I supposed to see
somebody to help me figure out me when I
mean even showers are hard at this point
of course so what you're like just so
I'm
clear when your husband comes
home and you have a three-year-old and a
one-year-old and you're very very
pregnant
and you start and you say how's your day
he said fine how's yours and you say it
was good um I need 30 minutes by myself
I need you to watch the little ones for
30 minutes I got a shower I haven't
showered I haven't gone to the bathroom
yet
today and he goes I doing
that no he says of course you do and
acts like annoyed and it's not that he's
annoyed to play with the kids cuz he
he's super great with the kids like
comes home and plays with them and um
but my youngest right now has become my
velcro baby and they're she cries and
instead of him trying to like divert her
attention to something outside or do
something else and he just gets
frustrated because she's going through
whatever she's going through right now
and then I feel guilty and I'm like well
then just forget it because I don't want
to put her through
that
sweetheart I
mean one-year-olds want their moms and
they cry
sometimes and when dads are frustrated
and tense kids feel the tension and the
frustration and they cry
more but if every time your kid cries
and doesn't learn how to be close to Dad
and Dad doesn't learn how to get some
little wins with this
one-year-old and you feel guilty and
come rescue him and rescue
her you can't then turn around and play
the
Martyr just let her be in that kind of
yes and then say
offline hey here's two or three or four
things that really help when she's
crying like
that I see you trying hard and I know
it's hard when that baby just won't stop
crying and when she's just stuck to me
like glue I get that it's hard try these
couple of
things what he usually does is let her
scream at the bathroom
door and it's like hard for me to take a
shower or if she's just screaming at me
at the baby gate while I'm trying to
cook dinner I can't have her with me
because it's dangerous or
something and he won't come
help I mean he'll say he'll call her a
name and tell her to come back to him
but he doesn't actually like physically
get her and distract her which I feel
like is I
mean I guess is what I do so I feel like
that's what's best because of that age
but maybe that's not what's best maybe
let them just no try it out at the gate
not what I'm saying at all not what I'm
saying at all I'm saying that it sounds
like a dad who's either a a terrible
human
being an absolute
lazy no good husband/father
who is so lazy he won't even get up and
pick up his one-year-old who's screaming
her brains out while mom's cooking
dinner or mom's trying to go to the
bathroom that's either that or he's a
dad without any tools in his
toolkit no he's a he's a horrible
husband he's an amazing father I mean he
lets him cry or whatever but like
like just a different parenting style
than I have I guess why haven't why
haven't you'all talked about
that
I me what do you I guess I don't know
what what do you
say in my house my wife was super
helpful because I never
babysat I had never changed a diaper
before I didn't know what I was
doing oh no I give him all the tips like
I'll even say hey will you take them out
and swing them so I can get XYZ done and
what does he
say like doesn't feel like
it where he like I feel like it's more
like a control thing where he doesn't
want to take my tips
because he feels like I'm controlling
the situation and he wants to watch the
kids how he wants to watch the kids and
that's maybe it's the way I come across
maybe it's the verbiage I use but it's
not my intention I just want my kids not
to cry at
me so so and and I'm trying to get
somewhere offline when the kids are
finally sleep and you crash on the couch
and he
crashes and you've turned and looked at
him and said hey we're not
okay yeah he says hold on be quiet I'm
trying to watch
TV no he gets frustrated
or like half the time he'll just fall
asleep mid conversation and I tell him
like I'm like I'm at my breaking point
in this marriage
I'm tired of being lonely I'm tired of
feeling like I'm doing this all on my
own
like I
mean and he doesn't really a lot of
times he doesn't respond he just like
will stare at me I'm not doing this with
you today or whatever that's it like I
feel like he just locks up super tight
and doesn't want to talk about
anything
but well here's the deal he's not here
I'm a talker so I don't know how to get
through any of it without talking and
figuring it out that's that's good but
he's not
here so I'll ask
you why haven't you packed up and gone
to your parents'
house if you have kids that are
screaming and a husband that won't help
that won't listen that looks at you and
says I'm not even I'm not even going to
honor you with a
response I'm just going to fall fall
sleep while you're
talking I'm not even going to listen to
your helpful tips even though you're
with the kids all day and I'm clearly
struggling why haven't you just gone to
your parents why are you choosing to
model this for your kids this is this
kids is what love looks
like um
because there's a whole
another aspect to the
story that your call probably doesn't
but basically he can
be uh very vindictive and mean and I
don't want my kids taken from
me why would your kids get taken from
you because he has a violet his
tree they wouldn't take them from you
they would take them from him has he
hurt
you in the
past why are you still there
because I do love him and I don't want
to be I don't know Ashley You're Not
Safe You're Not
Safe those kids aren't
safe are you involved in something that
if came to light they would take your
kids away from you are you struggling
with
addiction
no then why would
anybody you what I don't have any I
don't have any of those thing vices if
you will okay they usually don't take in
fact they never
take but if I'm not a
wife
because he's chose to get rid of me then
where my baby's goingon to go do you
think your husband's going to kill
you I don't I don't put myself in that
situation anymore let me be super clear
with you let me be super clear with you
I'm about to call the local police in
your
area you can't call this show and tell
me that you're scared for your life and
have me just do nothing I'm not I'm only
scared first of all I love him and I
want it to be with him okay he doesn't
want to be with you Ashley he doesn't
want to be with
you
[Music]
right so I only options to leave I'm
asking
you you're telling me he won't talk to
you he won't listen to you he won't
engage with
you you're scared for your you're scared
for your
life relationship stuff well you're
drowning you're dying you called me on I
how to mourn something how to be
dead I guess I was just hoping there was
a happy ending somewhere if I could just
find a way to be at peace with the cards
I was
dealt the cards I
chose because those cards aren't static
you can hand those cards back back to
the dealer and get another
set but you can't you absolutely can't
no you can get back out there and raise
your kids all alone and be that
potentially person but you're not GNA
find like I don't feel like you can find
anybody decent this day and age I think
that's 1,000%
incorrect it's not even close to reality
and I know that because I talk to him
every single day every
day here's what I think I think you've
lived scared to death for so
long I think you're so
exhausted I think you've got another
baby on the
way and that terrifies
you and as you said at the beginning of
the call you like to socially
isolate and your body is screaming at
you that you're not safe and you're all
by
yourself and when that happens sometimes
the whole world gets real
dim and so if you called me my hope that
you called is because you trust me and
I'm telling
you there is hope and there is light and
there are people that will help but you
have to be willing to take their help
and you have to be willing to say I'm
tired of living like this and I want to
do something
different when you're
safe then you
grieve I didn't want my marriage to look
like this I didn't want to be with a guy
that was unsafe I didn't want my kids to
grow up like this I didn't want to be a
single mom with three little
ones or I didn't want to have to go to a
bunch of counseling and try to fix this
thing
I don't even mind all that I just wanted
to loveely back I
know I
know but here's the deal here's what
we're going to do couple things number
one Jenna is gonna ask you very
specifically offline if you're safe
if there are any threats on your
life if there are we're calling the
police period end of
discussion number two we're going to get
you some free counseling with our
friends at better
help and you might have to call somebody
over to your house for 30 minutes to
watch your kid let somebody love
you you have to hear me say the greatest
gift you can give your kids right now is
that their mom is safe and
whole and that means the greatest gift
is not letting them you
know racing in there every time x y or Z
happens it's making sure you talk to a
professional therapist right
now it's making sure the police are
involved if you're not safe or this
person is
violent it's reaching out to your mom
and dad no you didn't want that but here
we
are the third thing is you got to go sit
with your mom and with your dad if
they're safe and say I need some
help and it might be asking him to leave
and if that's not safe or smart then you
pack up and say I got to be out here for
30 days while we figure out what's next
and if he calls and flips out and you
say I've tried to tell you that I'm not
safe in this marriage that I'm not okay
in this marriage and if we're going to
be back together we got to build
something
new but you don't just cash
out that quiet life of desperation this
is just the way this
is because people do change especially
when they get new
tools the sun come up and if worse comes
to worse there are some amazing people
out in the
world in this quote unquote day and age
there's a lot going on here and you need
to get to a professional
ASAP please please please make that call
today I've taken away all the barriers
for you I want you to make that call
hang on the line and Jenna's going to
pick
up